the anthem is always a giveaway
we weren't necessarily expecting the
queen
the walking stick a reminder she is
still having trouble when it comes to
getting around
last year she was able to inspect the
troops but this time a quick nudge and
prince edward was sent off instead
every year around now they spend a week
in scotland if this is more of a charm
offensive than usual with prince charles
and princess anne also on the way the
start was certainly subtle most didn't
even know she was here others wishing
she hadn't bothered we just came over to
see the palace as a landmark and
it's a surprise pro or you know um you
know
against uh are are
very want want the queen i don't really
support the queens do you know
the ceremony of the keys is how she's
always symbolically welcomed to
edinburgh immediately passing them back
for safekeeping
tomorrow it's the security and unity of
her united kingdom that will dominate
discussions with nicola sturgeon who the
queen is likely to meet again this week
setting out her plans for a second
independence referendum
how the queen feels about it we won't be
told but don't forget the last
referendum in 2014
a rare moment where her neutrality
appeared to slip apparently telling
churchgoers she hoped they would think
carefully she has therefore to be
extraordinarily
careful treading on uh eggshells to make
certain that no one can
uh quarter
uh a tense uh interpret anything that
she says uh as trying to
advise people to vote for remaining
within the union should that second
referendum occur
later in the week prince charles will
also join her after a difficult few days
where her heirs judgment has been called
into question with claims about his
charity his mother may increasingly need
his help but she is still determined to
carry out her own duties when she can
clearly pleased to be doing so north of
the border whatever the future of that
relationship may look like rihanna mills
sky news